Tijuana's downtown is squeaky clean.
Its main street is lined with bars, restaurants
and shops.
And it sports the unavoidable local absurdity
which serves as a tourist attraction.
These are the images the city of Tijuana wants
the world to see - in these days more than
ever.
The reality is very different.
Tijuana is sheltering almost three thousand
migrants from Central America – so called
“Caravan migrants” in the Benito Juarez
sports complex.
Now, with the number of migrants we have in
town the situation is under control and manageable.
We are cooperating and have the support of
the state police and other security agencies.
They may have control of the situation for
now.
But authorities expect that by the end of
the week an additional 900 migrants will have
arrived.
That influx could make conditions worse here,
things could become unmanageable quickly - A
major concern not only for city officials
and some locals.
A worry – shared even by Cindy and her three
sisters.
The women arrived here hours ago.
Making their way from Honduras in just over
a month they were separated from other family
members along the way.
Cindy can’t wait to get out of Tijuana and
into the US.
We are going to ask for asylum in the United
States, because we ran away from our country,
we are afraid in our country.
We don’t have work there, but most of all
we are afraid of the violence.
Cindy and her sisters know that asking for
asylum in the US is one thing, but that actually
qualifying for and getting it is much harder.
Everybody who has a god has hope.
Hope or not - Others don’t want to take
their chances.
Starting the legal asylum process is not an
option for them.
I will take the risk and jump the fence.
For the last four days another Honduran migrant
has been sheltering in Tijuana.
Francisco says he's lost faith in the U.S.
asylum process.
Why?
“I don’t want to ask for asylum, because
I heard that out of a thousand people just
about 10 get asylum.”
Tijuana– for most of the migrants just a
layover on their journey to their final destination,
the United States of America.
This family are here to request asylum.
Volunteers at the border crossing are helping
them with the application, which can take
at least two months to process.
That's a long time to wait without work or
shelter for Aurelio, his wife and four children.
Their journey from Guatemala already took
a month.
Having to wait here is what worries us.
We can't stay outside for so long.
It's very cold.
If Tijuana's government gives us the chance
to work, then we'll stay and see how we can
get into the US."
The local government has assured migrants
that they CAN work here.
But some experts doubt the city can support
so many in the long term.
There are around 7,000 jobs that could be
offered to both Mexicans and migrants.
The local manuacturing industry could employ
some, although it currently doesn't have much
hiring capacity.
The NGO that's helped the caravan -- Pueblos
Sin Fronteras -- is keen to point out any
opportunities.
The aid workers want to keep the migrants'
spirits high, and convince them of the dangers
of crossing the border illegally.
There are 20,000 jobs in construction that
even offer training to those without experience.
More than 500 people could die in a year when
tensions are high, because there's a lot of
violence."
The NGO is urging migrants to be patient.
But the lack of shelter and hostile atmosphere
in Tijuana is fuelling their despair.
More and more of them are considering climbing
the wall or even swimming around it.
Vladimir is one of them.
We're thinking about crossing by sea.
Wait until the waves go down, then take your
chance.
The migrants have little chance of being granted
asylum in the US under the Trump administration
although there's a bit more hope now that
a US court has barred Trump from denying asylum
to those entering illegally.
Some families are prepared to risk everything
to try.
If they don't let us in through the ports
of entry, we'll have to jump the wall.
There's no other way.
The biggest risk is on the other side.
We could get killed, but we have to help each
other cross the barrier.
The migrants AREN'T currently considering
jumping the wall en masse.
But they're also not ruling out protest action
to demand faster processing of asylum requests.
More Central American migrants are still making
their way towards Tijuana.
The Mexican government has installed metal
barriers at this border crossing for cars,
in order to stop a potential rush of people.
Die mexikanische Regierung hat diese Metallzäune
aufgestellt, um die Sicherheit an diesem Grenzübergang
für Autos angesichts eines möglichen Marsches
von Migranten hierher zu verstärken.
They face a dilemma: jump the wall or endure
the uncertain wait for asylum.